We did this long form piece in November of
2017 debunking a lot of the myths,
rounding, race and intelligence and Iq.
And we did it right after this topic sort
of exploded with Sam Harris and Charles Murray
and as recline and at the time there was just
a ton of discussion on youtube and elsewhere
about race and Iq and I thought it was necessary
at the time to deconstruct some of the so
called scientific racism narratives, which
have actually always been around.
But we're really popularized right around
that time, about a year and a half ago or
so.
And I wasn't gonna do any more on the subject.
I think we said what we needed to say.
It's not something that we talk about often
on the program very much anymore, but I decided
to do a sort of one time follow up to that
video.
Um, based on the feedback that I've gotten
since then.
The video that we originally did got more
than a quarter million views.
It has about 30% dislikes, which is not super
surprising.
It still gets views and I'm continuing to
hear from about it.
And I want to address a couple of the different
types of criticisms that I get about the video.
People have said things like, if it's okay
to say that certain races are better at sports,
why is it wrong to make the same sort of observations
about race and intelligence?
Now this kind of argument isn't always worded
in this exact same way, but it's a common
one that you hear.
And I think that this athletics and intelligence
analogy could maybe be a good jumping off
point to explore racial taboos and what a
lot of people just aren't understanding about
this.
So to begin with, if we're just talking about
taboos, many people do find it offensive when
certain races are stereotyped as being better
at sports.
Racial stereotypes tend to be offensive to
a lot of people, whether they're positive
or negative stereotypes.
But going beyond that, stereotypes about athletic
ability and stereotypes about intellectual
ability have very different implications.
And people who equate the two are just pretending
that they don't know that or genuinely don't
know it.
Most employers don't care about the natural
athletic abilities of a job applicant.
Being stereotyped as someone who's probably
good at sports or certain sports is not going
to significantly impact you in most of the
real world.
With some exceptions.
Being stereotyped as someone who's probably
smart, very well may help you in life.
So being equated, equating athletics with
intelligence in order to argue that race and
Iq shouldn't be taboo or shouldn't be handled
with sensitivity is probably just pretending
not to understand that there's a real significant
difference between the two.
When someone says, we can talk about race
and athletic ability, so we should be allowed
to talk about race and intelligence.
This person might also be ignoring the social
causes behind why certain races are more successful
in certain sports.
The same way that people ignore the social
aspects of Iq, certain sports are way more
ingrained in certain cultures.
So for example, despite Latin Americans, disproportionate
representation in baseball would be pretty
ridiculous to say that they are genetically
predisposed to excel at baseball or to say
that northern Europeans have a genetic inclination
to be better bobsledders.
In some cultures bowling is more present and
other cultures it's track and field that's
more common.
Basketball plays a bigger role in some cultures
than in others.
So someone trying to say that Iq is genetically
tied to race and that we should be allowed
to talk about it because we do the same thing
for sports might be committing the exact same
fallacies when thinking about sports as when
they do with Iq from a social perspective
and somebody trying to make this point might
also be failing to recognize that intellectual
ability is orders of magnitude more dynamic
and complex than athletic ability from a biological
perspective, which they claim to care about.
We can say with significant certainty exactly
what makes someone a better runner versus
being better at lifting heavier weight versus
being better at throwing a ball.
You can't reduce in jet intelligence to the
same kind of analysis.
So someone making this argument, comparing
or equating sports to intelligence is on multiple
levels equivocating or not even understanding
this debate in response to what I've previously
said about race and Iq.
Something else I've been seeing people defend
is this premise that regardless of what other
conclusions we can or cannot make about Iq,
Iq tests are simply really good predictors
of success in life and people often use this
either to justify the utility of Iq tests
and keeping Iq tests as part of the conversation
about race and intelligence as well as to
explain why racist, who score lower on Iq
tests also have lower incomes or whatever
other parameter it is that they're focused
on.
So let's reset this.
What Iq tests are best at indicating is whether
or not someone has a serious lack of intelligence.
Okay.
Iq tests measure very specific things, short
term memory, some pattern recognition, some
verbal abilities, processing speed to some
degree, visual, spatial processing, a particular
type of comprehension.
There is no question at all that if someone
scores an 80 on an Iq test that they are lacking
in those categories as measured and relevant
by the Iq test.
But that's somebody who has some pretty serious
challenges.
Anyone who, uh, accepts that Iq tests are
effective at screening out.
People who have significant cognitive limitations
would then have to ask the question, well,
at minimum if you have normal intelligence
or higher, what is Iq really tell us about
success?
And the answer is not very much.
Iq scores among people with normal intelligence
can give us a sense of who's better at taking
tests or better at accomplishing tasks that
are similar to Iq tests and at doing jobs
that require thinking in narrow boundaries
like an Iq test.
And some might call them paper pushers.
That's what an a Taleb calls I why eyes or
intellectuals yet idiots.
This is his term, not mine.
So when we're trying to determine whether
they're actually are correlations between
Iq and success, how are we measuring success?
Let's for a moment say that you could measure
success by wealth or income.
It's not the only way.
Many people do really great important things
and they don't make a lot of money, but in
western capitalist society we might look at
wealth as at least one factor that we would
say success and wealth are not interchangeable
but significantly complimentary.
There is no statistically significant correlation
between Iq and wealth beyond seriously cognitively
limited people.
You can definitely come up with some kind
of sort of circular reasoning to say people
with high Iq have more bureaucratic success.
They hold higher positions on paper at different
institutions.
They do well in these hierarchically based
jobs that are similar to Iq tests, which wouldn't
be a big surprise but there's no correlation
with wealth.
When someone with a High Iq has a job with
tasks that are like an Iq test, they're going
to do well, but that doesn't correlate Iq
with success as defined by wealth just with
success that is similar to the Iq test themselves.
Check out this chart plotting net worth versus
Iq at the bottom.
You'll see that for Iqs ranging from 70 to
90 there is definitely a clustering of low
net worth.
Once you get past the Iq Range, 70 to 90,
it is a very statistically noisy distribution
or instead of wealth.
You can also look at Iq versus income.
Definitely a slight correlation, but income
is not rising nearly as fast as Iq, especially
once you get past that 70 to 90 Iq range where
it almost levels out totally from a scientific
perspective.
What we have here is a correlation that works
in the left tail but not the right tail, which
suggests that Iq is mostly useful for identifying
people who are seriously limited in their
intellectual capacity.
You see the correlation with so called success
at low Iqs, but the correlation goes away
high iqs.
This makes it a bad predictive measure beyond
telling us who has really serious learning
disabilities, which by the way, we can figure
out without Iq tests.
Another important factor, uh, you know how
lots of people on the right like to say academia
isn't real life.
They say, you know, the real world simply
doesn't work like an academic sociology department
or like a liberal arts college.
The same applies to the concept of an Iq test.
In the real world when you're presented with
Iq type questions, it's not just about getting
the right answer within those artificial constraints.
You have to figure out is is this question
relevant?
You have to figure out why am I being asked
this question.
You have to figure out is my time better spent
elsewhere than answering this question and
is Nassim Taleb has written an Iq test asks
you in a sequence one, two, three, four x,
what is x?
Finding x in that limited away is very rarely
something people are asked to do in the real
world, but more importantly in the real world
people would say, why is it important to find
x?
Iq does not measure that, but real world success
depends on that type of thinking.
So once again to compare Iq and success, let's
look at Iq relative to specific elements of
job performance.
Correlations go from minus one to one.
Okay, so anything from zero and up means that
there is a correlation.
A correlation of one would be total correlation.
Like for example, the correlation between
being homo sapiens and being human is one
training success in the military.
And Iq have a slightly larger than 0.6 correlation.
On the other hand, job performance in medium
complexity jobs correlates with Iq at about
0.5.
Creativity correlates with Iq below 0.4 and
leader effectiveness correlates with Iq at
roughly 0.3.
So you can still look at that and say, well
listen, 0.6 correlations are pretty high and
you're right.
But once you account for a bell curve distribution,
you have to realize why this is a very limited
usefulness to us.
If we look at just the correlation between
Iq and performance in general, it looks like
this.
This doesn't make any sense unless as I mentioned,
Iq is merely a tool to identify people who
are significantly limited in their intelligence
and cognitive abilities.
These correlations are low enough that there
is a massive overlap between supposedly low
Iq and high Iq jobs.
Uh, check out this chart which shows a whole
bunch of different jobs and the Iq ranges
of the people who do them.
A Quick Lancet at this looks very overwhelming.
Wow.
The IQ range of janitors and machine operators
and truck drivers is just so much lower than
the Iq for doctors and professors and electrical
engineers.
But remember these are ranges and if you look
very closely at this, you'll notice that the
top 25% of janitors have a higher Iq than
the bottom 25% of college professors.
And of course part of this is circular because
medical school requires that you've done well
on things like sats, which correlates with
Iq because they're testing very similar things.
Imagine how many lower Iq people could be
doctors if more opportunities were given to
people without high sat scores who might still
be a great doctor or a great professor if
the tests required to be a professor or doctor
require high Iq, that's going to restrict
those fields to people with higher Iq without
ever having to demonstrate that the high Iq
is actually necessary to be successful in
those fields.
So yeah, the people who peddle the race realist
stuff about Iq are usually the same people
who have this mantra about how important Iq
is and how fatalistic and linked to success
it is, which makes sense because Iq tests
being relevant or useful to begin with is
a necessary premise for everything else that
follows in these hypotheses.
They will say Iq tests are an authoritative
measure of intelligence and it's the most
accurate measure of intelligence and of human
potential, and that's how the race realists
ensure that the next claim really comes with
a sting.
The claim that black people or Hispanic people
or whoever are on average destined to have
lower iqs.
So basically those groups are predetermined
to live measurably lower quality lives and
that's just that.
It might be sad, we might not like it, but
it's the truth.
But Iq doesn't measure all types of intelligence
or even measure potential for success in life.
It doesn't even really measure your full potential
to perform on the IQ tests themselves.
Children's Iq test scores can increase with
certain type of educational interventions
and with changes in environments people have
the same genetic Iq potential for lack of
a better term, would score differently when
raised in different parental or socioeconomic
situations.
Environment is a massive factor and one of
the most interesting counterpoints to the
racial Iq success theory is Polynesians native
Polynesians are a racially or ethnically homogenous
group that's spread out over a massive, massive
environment ranging from within New Zealand,
throughout islands in the Pacific all the
way to Easter island with drastically different
levels of success in economics, in technology
development, in food production, longevity,
and in many other factors what matters, where
the environments they spread to, which allowed
very different food production.
When you have a food production surplus that
dictates when you can actually start to have
members of your population specialize in tasks
beyond the gathering of food itself, you start
to develop politics and technology and ultimately
the level of success as measured by modern
western standards is heavily dependent on
this.
Now, there are ways in which Iq is partly
heritable.
There are studies involving identical twins
who are raised in separate environments or
adopted children not raised by their biological
parents that show this.
There is not a total consensus as to to what
degree Iq is heritable or how strong the correlation
is between differences in Iq and differences
in Geno types.
Iq heritability can even vary widely based
on when and where you study it.
Under what circumstances making it much more
difficult to nail down.
Is it a point to correlation is at 0.5 is
it something else but there's not much disagreement
that Iq can be genetically inherited.
To some extent it's more than zero but it's
definitely not one.
But then the question is is that the complete
story or even nearly enough of it to what
it tells us about the Iqs of groups of people
and are there other facts that would complicate
things for people who take Quinn's studies
and presume that it points to inherent average
Iq differences that can be based on race and
the answer is what happens in individuals
does not even necessarily have any bearing
on what happens in groups.
Imagine you have group A and Group B group
a has higher average Iq scores Than Group
B and you want to know is that because of
genetic differences between the two groups
to confirm that that's the case, you would
need one specific identifiable genes that
consistently cause people to have higher iqs
and group a would need to on average have
more of those genes than group B has.
And number two, the difference in Iq between
the two groups would need to be greater than
that which could be explained by the environment.
And we know that this isn't the case when
we're talking about races.
Research has shown us that the Iq differences
we see between races is no greater than the
Iq differences we observe between children
raised in different environments.
We also know that Iqs in the United States
and worldwide have risen more quickly in the
past hundred years than could ever be accounted
for by genetics.
Iq is highly malleable depending on environment.
And then last but definitely not least as
an extremely important crux in all of this.
If you're dealing with something biological,
like genetic Iq, you have to be weighing it
against something that is also biological.
It would be totally meaningless.
For example, for us to do research on the
correlation between having red hair and being
a libertarian one is a biological trait.
One is a socially constructed trait.
Race is a socially constructed trait, not
a distinct biological concept, but this is
the position of the Nih, the APA, the American
anthropological association.
There is no gene or set of genes that all
people from one race have.
There's so much genetic diversity within what
we refer to as races that any conversation
about weighing a biological variable like
genetic Iq against race is moot from the beginning,
but some people were even saying that the
NIH and the APA take this position on race
because they are institutions controlled by
liberals.
I do want to just break this down again because
it really is what makes the entire race realist
argument about genetic Iq completely implode
in biology.
We do not have genetically discrete groups
based on continent of origin or skin color
or what we would call black, white, Asian,
Indian, Hispanic.
We have patterns of continuous variation from
a continental all the way down to the population
level rather than these abrupt clear differences
between continental.
This is an example we used in the other video,
but I think it's a good one.
Sickle cell anemia, there's a misconception
that black people get this disease because
there's something genetically that black people
have in common.
Here's a map of the distribution of sickle
cell anemia, which is common in the Middle
East in India as well because it develops
where malaria is common.
It has nothing to do with being black or African
and black people sharing DNA.
There's nothing that all Africans or Asians
or white people have in common within their
races that's not shared between races, but
you might be thinking people within races
half to share something genetically because
I can look at someone and I can tell what
race they are.
There are physical features in common and
these are based on genes like for example,
these two people.
Clearly these are two people of African descent.
There's something visually distinct about
people of African descent.
You'd be wrong.
The man on the left is an aboriginal Australian
and the boy on the right is a Giraffe, Wawa
and indigenous people of the Andaman Islands
in Southeast Asia.
We learned nothing about their genetics by
looking at them.
And you're average person from either of these
two regions would have very little in common
genetically with someone from Africa.
Dark Skin, uh, dark.
Kinky hair is an adaptive trait that develops
in people who live near the equator on any
continent.
And by the same token, a person from Nigeria
and a person from Zimbabwe wouldn't be assumed
to necessarily have much in common genetically
either.
Neither would someone from France and someone
from Russia, even though they may both look
white.
So you quickly realize why trying to correlate
a specific genetic trait with a genetically
arbitrary variable like race or continent
doesn't get you anywhere.
You have to under the understand the difference
here between the general notion of Iq being
heritable on an individual basis from parent
to child, which is all that we actually learned
from the twin studies where we see Iq inherited
to some degree and the more specific notion
that there's evidence for average genetic
Iq differences between races, which would
then also assume that race is even a valid
factor biologically against which to measure
genetic Iq differences.
It's time to move on from this.
It's passe.
I know I will get another series of rebuttals
from people in the audience, but for the time
being, we've said more than enough about race
and I,
and there are really important issues that
we actually have to solve on planet earth
for Homo Sapiens.